senior political analyst Brit Hume joins
us tonight Brett this is a district
that's not even going to exist next year
but it's all about bragging rights
tomorrow night well it's interesting
that there's so much being spent to fill
briefly a congressional seat that's
about to go away because the
Pennsylvania Supreme Court threw out the
the districting plan that had been drawn
up by the by the legislature and replace
it with one that a state makes makes
this one go away so what we have is a
special election to fill out that
unexpired term in the seat that won't be
there anymore and and all kinds of money
and after they're being put into it this
is an interesting the crosscurrents John
in this in this race are almost too
numerous to count in addition to the
fact that it's a district it's about to
disappear it is a it has been a majority
Democrat district which Republican
member has held for what you know six or
seven terms are longer in addition of
course that Republican Tim Murphy was
was excused from Congress excused
himself from Congress after a sex
scandal which generally bodes well for
the predecessor of this of the successor
excuse me of the same party but and and
not to mention that Democrats will come
up with a pretty intriguing candidate
young attractive telegenic marine
veteran and so on so the ingredients
right here the disc could certainly go
either way
2016 breath the president won this
district by almost 20 points the fact
that this race is even closed that
people aren't just expecting the the
Republican to walk away with it what did
what does that say either about the
state of the Republican Party the
candidate or the president
well it says a couple things to me
anyway one of them is that this this
tremendous antipathy toward Donald Trump
among Democrats means that Democrats are
motivated as they would not normally be
in an election like this to come out and
vote this is a way to register your your
objections to Donald Trump in addition
to that of course the as I mentioned the
Democratic candidate is is kind of cute
and the Republican candidate is kind of
a frumpy guy and you know that adds adds
into the mix so you know but I don't
think though that in a race like this
with so many cross currents for you know
for an election that
then I'd be repeated basically comes a
fall that you can draw all that many
conclusions from it but I guarantee you
this if the if the Democrats win this
seat they will claim that they've got
the momentum for a huge blue wave in the
fall and if the Republicans managed to
hold the seat what with the president
having come in there over the weekend
and and campaigned for this for this
Republican candidate you're gonna hear
mr. Trump saying that it was a big win
for him in your long storied career of
political analysis I've never heard you
say and he's kind of cute well that's
what you wanted to get a gun he wanted
to be pretty cute brett hume forested
eye Brett thanks so much